everyone knows that mary-kate and Ashley
Olsen used their super twin powers to
bring Michelle Turner to life on full
house fun fun I'm also a twin no way huh
yes but a twin stepping in as a body
double or playing half of the role isn't
just reserved for flirty toddlers
identical twins have popped up in lots
of films and TV shows about you ever
noticing and while some on-screen
doubles aren't quite perfect fits my
name is Julius and am your twin brother
obviously you might be surprised that
some of the roles that were played by
twins Sofia per set in orange is the new
black one of the slickest twin twists in
TV history is Anna Netflix mash based on
Piper Kerman prison memoir creator Jenji
Kohan and her crew tried to use
transgender icon Laverne Cox and her
character's pre-transition flashback
scenes but the episodes famous director
wasn't buying Sofia as Marcus and Jodie
Foster directed episodes I was the
captain Richard happy I don't think
believed that I could I could pull this
off and then go to jury she looks like
we have to hire someone fortunately they
didn't have to look far they decided to
hire Cox his identical twin a composer
and singer who performs under the name
em Lamar we proved to be a perfect fit
he had no previous acting experience or
training but you wouldn't know it his
performance and look was so seamless
most viewers probably just assumed it
was Cox from the role of Marcus aided by
Hollywood magic my friends were like how
did they do that with that CGI or
something Sarah Connor in Terminator 2
Judgment Day science fiction fans and
critics raved over Linda Hamilton's
badass performance and t2 cat white and
then a few scenes audiences were graced
with double the Hamilton most notably
when the t1000 mimic Sarah Connor
director James Cameron it didn't need to
break out the early 90s CG magic or pull
an old-school Patty Duke split-screen
yeah Kamran simply used Hamilton's
identical twin sister Leslie to get the
shot Xander Harris and Buffy the Vampire
Slayer in their season 5 episode the
replacement Xander lovers were treated
to a double dose of sarcasm and snark
what do we do if it doesn't work kill us
both Spock to pull off the trick on a
skimpy TV budget the show use a very low
five solution Nicholas Brendon identical
twin brother Kelly Donovan Brendon
however still performed both roles
Donovan only spoke when photos Anders
had lined in the same scene
cover your eyes it'll melt your brain
Clare Kincaid in law and order actress
Jill Hennessy was once so busy in her
role as assistant district attorney on a
long-running NBC procedural she
literally needed to be in two places at
once
fortunately she had a twin who happily
filled Claire Kincaid shoes in 1996
Jacqueline Hennessy worked as an
uncredited stand-in for her sister in a
few scenes in one season six episode
because Jill was busy filming a
crossover episode of homicide life on
the street this wasn't Jacqueline's
first time on camera the Hannity sisters
made their film debut as twin escort and
the 1988 David Cronenberg film Dead
Ringers
chord Foster and the man in the moon
addict - Jason London best known for his
role in 1993's Dazed and Confused made
his film debut in the 1991 coming-of-age
drama the man in the moon his twin
Jeremy best known for party of five and
the mall rats was actually the one who
wanted to audition for the film and
convinced his brother to drive him there
Jason read for the part soon beating his
brother else but Jeremy was still
involved with the production while Jason
got to do all the acting including
kissing Reese Witherspoon in a film
debut his twin brother Jeremy was on
hand for all the Ingram or stunt work
including the infamous tractor incident
so that sucks for him The Matrix
though the 1999 science fiction classic
used cutting-edge special effects for
some revolutionary shoves the Wachowskis
chose to go practical for the agent
training seen as neo walks through the
stream of people if you look closely you
can see that faces keep repeating that's
because the crowd is full of identical
siblings the directing duo said they
couldn't afford to pull off the effect
of digitally at the time so the end
hiring of many twins or triplets that
they could find in Sydney where the film
was shot so if you've ever wondered why
that scene felt extra creepy is your
answer thanks for watching click the
loop icon to subscribe to our YouTube
channel plus check out all this cool
stuff we know you're nothing
[Applause]